one of the greatest illusions in life is
continuity 66 million years ago
the continuity of the dinosaurs had been
going on for around
165 million years already and it didn't
seem this would change anytime
soon the world was warm and pleasant and
most of the land was covered with lush
forests
and an incredible diversity of trees
flowers
ferns and trillions of critters
dinosaurs were ubiquitous and had
diversified into hundreds of species of
all shapes and sizes
titanators large gentle giants shared
the world with famous beasts like
tyrannosaurus rex
or edmontosaurus hectinodon hunted in
the undergrowth
while edmontosaurus wandered coastlines
and swamps
an ancient paradise a world of plenty
full of life 66 million years ago
maybe on a tuesday afternoon life was
the same as it had been the day before
or a thousand years before or pretty
much a million years before
things were good for our feathered
dinosaur buddies
until a tiny tiny detail in the sky
changed
[Music]
if there were dinosaurs watching the
stars one night
they may have noticed the appearance of
a new star a tiny dot
that for many weeks slowly became bigger
and brighter
until one fateful day it looked like
another
small moon in the night sky and then
it faded from sight as it dipped into
earth's shadow
for a few more hours the illusion of
continuity
was upheld until it was not anymore
in the morning the object suddenly
appears again
now almost as large as the sun in the
sky and growing every moment
heading for the coast near the yucatan
peninsula
it takes the asteroid only seconds to
pass through the thin layer between
space and the ground
to make contact as it enters the
atmosphere
at almost 60 times the speed of sound
let's stop time here we see the unnamed
asteroid
about to commit specieside
larger than mount everest it reaches
from the ocean
high into the atmosphere higher than
passenger planes would fly millions of
years later
at this moment the world was one way in
a fraction of a second
it would be fundamentally different
let's make the transition
as the asteroid hits the shallow ocean
and the bedrock below
the energy of billions of nuclear
weapons is released
all at once as the asteroid vaporizes
a flash of light illuminates the sky as
an eerie bright white sphere grows over
the gulf of mexico
bedrock melts into seething hot plasma
at tens of thousands
of degrees celsius the thermal radiation
from the explosion
travels at the speed of light and
immediately burns everything within a
radius of about one thousand
five hundred kilometers while the energy
from the impact
pushes so hard against earth's crust
that it loses all strength
and flows away from the impact site like
a liquid
creating a hole 25 kilometers deep and
100 kilometers wide
the ocean is pushed back for hundreds of
kilometers like when a kid jumps into a
puddle
as the crust bounces back melted and
flowing crust forms a temporary mountain
stretching 10 kilometers into the sky an
incredible amount of material is blasted
into the higher atmosphere
or even out into space as much as 60
times the original mass of the asteroid
the violence of the strike is felt
everywhere on earth within minutes
a magnitude 11 earthquake may be the
most powerful quake any living thing has
ever witnessed
in billions of years it is so insanely
strong
that in india it might have shaken
gigantic lava fields
and causes volcanic eruptions that would
last for 30
000 years and cover half of the indian
subcontinent with lava
even on the side of earth opposite the
impact the ground
still moved by several meters nobody
would sleep through this day
the gigantic explosion crashes against
the atmosphere with
unprecedented violence and causes a
shock wave that reaches speeds of more
than 1 000 kilometers per hour near the
site of impact
similar to the hyper hurricanes on gas
giants like neptune
in middle america basically any soil
vegetation
or animal is just shredded into pieces
and catapulted thousands of kilometers
away
now the previously displaced oceans
return as the temporary mountain at the
site of impact collapses
a ring of tsunamis as high as one
kilometer enough to cover all
skyscrapers humans would ever build
heads in all directions as they crash
into the coasts of the continents
surrounding the impact they will drown
thousands of kilometers of coastline
15 hours later some of the waves that
get refracted around south america
will still tower as much as 100 meters
into the sky
but we still haven't talked about the
worst thing yet
a lot of the debris heated into space
will orbit earth for thousands of years
some may hit the moon or even mars
but most of it comes right back when
things fall through the atmosphere at
such speed
they get very hot as in hundreds of
degrees hot
and this happens to millions of tons of
material everywhere
this rapidly heats up the atmosphere to
insane
temperatures we don't know exactly how
hot it got or how long this heat shock
lasted but there are two ideas here
either the air was heated to hundreds of
degrees for a few minutes
or two thousands of degrees for around
one minute
in any case the air became as hot as the
inside of an industrial
oven how bad the global effects of this
were is contested
but if enough heat reached the surface a
lot of plants and animals would have
died
very quickly if they couldn't bury
themselves or escape into caves
the heat together with raining debris
also may have ignited material on forest
floors
and sparked wildfires as the earth
rotated
under the searing hot blue in a few
hours
massive wildfires were probably burning
around the globe
some of them may have lasted for months
and turned earth
into a horrifying hot hellish version of
itself
as the day of the impact draws to an end
many of the dinosaurs are already dead
but the worst is still to come
the gigantic plume of vaporized material
reaches the upper atmosphere
and spreads around the whole globe
together with the soot from the burning
planet
and the aerosols generated at impact the
planet sinks into a deep darkness
with only the remaining raging fires
illuminating the scenery
whatever plants survive the firestorms
will now be starved for sunlight
as global photosynthesis is temporarily
shut down
within days temperatures crash as much
as 25 degrees celsius
the oceans were especially hard hit the
lack of sunlight killed over 90 percent
of plankton
which formed the basis of the food web
of marine life
ultimately this would kill off the large
marine reptiles
and ammonites that used to dominate the
seas
the biosphere the survivors now find
themselves in
is like an alien landscape ash debris
and the burned remains of the formerly
lush and blooming life
cover the ground the sky is dark and
it's cold
and fresh food is scarce while fungi
thrive
for months and years the planet will be
a hostile
and deadly place the sudden global
winter
will last for decades at least 75
percent of
all species on earth will just vanish
from existence
and so as the day ends the world
is suddenly different the continuity
that went on for millions of years
is no more the era of the dinosaurs
is over just like that
eventually from the ashes of the old
world survivors emerged
birds that are the direct descendants of
the dinosaurs
and mammals that would eventually become
the dominant animals on the planet
without the asteroid who knows what life
on earth would look like today
without the sudden disruption of
dinosaur continuity
that completely changed the planet and
all life on it
we might have never had the opportunity
to become what we are today
it's not clear how long the human error
will last
so far modern humans have been around
for 0.1 percent of the time the
dinosaurs were
and in this short amount of time we've
achieved impressive feats
from making the world our own to
reaching space
and splitting the atom yet our future
and our long-term survival are not a
given
if we're not careful it could end in an
instant
like the age of the dinosaurs ended but
in contrast to them
we know that our continuity is fragile
even if it doesn't feel like it
we can be prepared and be vigilant and
hopeful
if we're lucky our journey will go on
for a long long time
speaking of journeys we want to address
something in the spirit of transparency
koskazak has changed in the last two
years we've become more than a youtube
channel or animation studio
and now also run a paper shop that sells
hundreds of thousands of calendars
posters and notebooks that's not a happy
accident
many of us have a background in graphic
design paper products are our roots
and we actually started out creating
posters books and print infographics
we love that you can touch them smell
them nerd about small details and
printing techniques
just like the channel we started small
and without great ambition
step by step we found the right printers
and papers
learned about shipping and expanded our
shop we put a huge amount of research
love and hours into it because this is
the only way we know how to do things
we don't just want to make generic merge
we want to make things that fit our
mission of making science exciting
and creating beautiful things things
that persist
and are made with high quality and love
our shop gives us another outlet to do
this and as a nice side effect
has turned into our main source of
income for everything we do on this
channel
which also keeps us independent and our
videos free for everyone
so we want to build further on that and
create more things that last
we've just started a new notebook line
called pocket log
that will expand on in the future the
first edition is a dinosaur themed
collection that will hopefully serve a
future paleontologist well
there are loads of plans for sciencey
stuff more journals and
calendars and infographics let us know
what you would like us to make
for your room kids classrooms and
yourself
in the end the things we do work because
you like them
and because you enable us to put
thousands of hours into videos
and hundreds of hours into posters and
journals
thank you so much for that we're looking
forward to making fun sciency stuff for
you
no matter if it's a video a poster or
something else entirely
thank you for watching
[Music]
you